THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS SAID IT PLANS TO
APPEAL A COURT-ORDERED SPECIAL
MASTER TO REVIEW THE MATERIALS
SEIZED BY THE FBI AT MAR-A-LAGO,
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BEACH HOME.
THE DOJ IS ACTUALLY FILING A
MOTION WITH A FEDERAL JUDGE
CARVING OUT PART OF HER RULING,
SAYING THAT THE FBI SHOULD BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE SEIZED
THERE.
WITH US NOW CNN LEGAL ANALYST
NORM EISEN, THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE'S SPECIAL COUNSEL
DURING DONALD TRUMP'S FIRST
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
I KNOW YOU AGREE WITH WHAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS DOING
HERE, I KNOW YOU DISAGREE WITH
JUDGE CANON'S ORIGINAL RULING.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN EXACTLY WHAT
THEY'RE ASKING HERE?
IT'S AN INTERESTING CARVEOUT.
>> JOHN, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
BACK.
YES, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
SAYING TO JUDGE CANNON, WE'RE
NOT GOING TO APPEAL RIGHT NOW
YOUR DECISION TO APPOINT A
SPECIAL MASTER OR PROHIBIT US
FROM USING THE 11,000
NONCLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, BUT FOR
A SMALL SUBSET OF DOCUMENTS THAT
WERE SEIZED BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WHEN IT EXECUTED ITS
SEARCH WARRANT AT MAR-A-LAGO A
BIT OVER 100 DOCUMENTS THEY'RE
SAYING, JUDGE, DON'T STOP US
FROM USING THESE WHILE WE
INVES
INVESTIGATE, ISSUE A STAY OF
YOUR EARLIER ORDER SO THAT WE
CAN APPEAL THIS TO THE 11th
CIRCUIT.
THEY'VE GIVEN UP ON HER, THEY
ARE NOT ASKING HER TO
RECONSIDER, THEY'RE GOING TO GO
UP ON APPEAL BUT IN THE MEANTIME
THEY SAY DON'T TIE OUR HANDS ON
THESE DOCUMENTS, IT'S DANGEROUS
TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> SO WHY?
WHY THESE DOCUMENTS?
WHAT'S THE JUSTIFICATION TO LET
THEM CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THESE
ROUGHLY, I UNDERSTAND, 100
DOCUMENTS?
>> WELL, THE JUSTIFICATION IS
THAT THE JUDGE SAID IN HER
EARLIER ORDER, JOHN, THAT SHE
WAS GOING TO BIFURCATE.
SHE WAS GOING TO ALLOW -- THESE
DOCUMENTS ARE SO DANGEROUS AND
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS AS A
FORMER DIPLOMATE WHO HAD OUR
NATION'S HIGHEST SECURITY
CLEARANCE AND WHO ACTUALLY
WORKED ON THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
THAT THE GOVERNMENT REALIZE UPON
TO MAKE THIS ARGUMENT WHEN I WAS
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, THIS
DIVISION THAT SHE'S MADE MAKES
NO SENSE.
SHE SAYS, HEY, THESE DOCUMENTS
ARE SO DANGEROUS WE'RE GOING TO
ALLOW THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
TO DO A DAMAGE ASSESSMENT.
ARE WE BURNING THE IDENTITIES OF
SPIES?
ARE WE ENDANGERING AMERICANS OR
OUR ALLIES BY HAVING THESE
DOCUMENTS IN AN INSECURE
LOCATION?
BUT, FBI, DOJ, YOU CAN'T LOOK AT
THEM.
JOHN, THE FBI AND THE DOJ ARE
PART OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
IF IT'S DANGEROUS ENOUGH AND WE
SEEM TO HAVE THAT HERE, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND OTHERS IN
HIS BUILDING NEED TO BOTH DO THE
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION AND THE
DAMAGE ASSESSMENT.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN'T PUT A
WALL UP IN THE MIDDLE OF HIS
BRAIN.
SO THEY'RE SAYING, HEY, YOUR
ORDER ESSENTIALLY ENDANGERS
NATIONAL SECURITY, PLEASE STAY
THAT PART OF THE ORDER WHILE WE
APPEAL IT.
>> NORM, DOJ IS SAYING THAT THAT
INTELLIGENCE DAMAGE ASSESSMENT
ACTUALLY HAS TO PAUSE.
THAT THESE THINGS ARE TOO
INTERTWINED FOR THAT TO GO ON IF
SHE HAS THIS INJUNCTION.
FIRST OFF, DOES THAT MAKE SENSE
TO YOU?
AND, DO YOU THINK THAT THE JUDGE
IS GOING TO FIND THAT COMPELLING
ENOUGH THAT SHE'S GOING TO SAY,
OKAY, THAT MAKES SENSE?
>> WELL, BRIANNA, WE HAD A
LITTLE CLUE THAT THE JUDGE IS
TAKING -- JUDGE CANNON IS TAKING
IT VERY SERIOUSLY BECAUSE AFTER
DOJ FILED, SHE ORDERED THE
PARTIES IN THE SPECIAL MASTER
RECOMMENDATIONS, WHO THE SPECIAL
MASTER SHOULD BE AND THE
SO-CALLED ORDER OF OPERATIONS,
HOW THE SPECIAL MASTER WILL
WORK, EVEN THOUGH SHE HASN'T
RULED ON THE STAY MOTION, SHE
SAID I WANT BOTH PARTIES TO
ADDRESS HOW DOJ'S MOTION WILL
AFFECT THE CHOICE AND OPERATION
OF THE SPECIAL MASTER.
SO I THINK THAT'S A TELL THAT
SHE'S TAKING THIS SERIOUSLY.
BRIANNA, DOJ HAS GIVEN HER A
LIFE LINE.
THIS IS THE WORST AND MOST
DANGEROUS PART OF HER ORDER AND
IF SHE'S SMART SHE WILL TAKE IT
AND SHE WILL STAY THIS PART OF
THE ORDER.
I REALLY DO THINK IT JEOPARDIZES
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY IF SHE
DOESN'T.
>> YEAH, THEY'RE KIND OF SAYING
UNPRETZEL YOURSELF OR WE'RE
HEADING TO THE 11th CIRCUIT FOR
AN ACTUAL APPEAL HERE.
NORM, GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.